[Musique]
patricia terrier bonjour bonjour merci
d'être présente sur le plateau de tv fil
pour ce vide si vous y consacrez vous
êtes photographe yvelinois photographe
et je suis ravi parce que c'est la
première fois que je reçois un
photographe donc vous allez être
bombardés de questions préparées vous
voilà un peu d'histoire
vous venez d'où exactement moi je suis
né en normandie normandy village du
bessin et après je suis venu travailler
à paris dans le 6e arrondissement où il
y avait donc une grosse différence entre
mon petit village normand c'est le 6ème
arrondissement et par la suite fut venu
habiter dans les yvelines dans les 78 78
d'accord mais non ça fait un un petit
peu de temps quand même que vous êtes
yvelinois déjà on parle de vous
aujourd'hui parce que vous êtes vos
oeuvres sont exposées à ou dans un lieu
qui s'appelle la tannerie
il y reviendra à la fin de l'émission
voilà et on va pouvoir parler de votre
travail du coup et et moi je me
demandais comment est venue cette
vocation de photographes parce que déjà
à 10 ans vous êtes dit quand je serai
grand je serai photographes ou pas
comment c'est venu non à 10 ans non mais
on m'avait offert des appareils photo
graphique dont le jeune et puis je me
souviens aussi d'avoir emprunté
l'appareil de mon père qui était un peu
plus perfectionnés qui déjà guise mais
même ça teresa qui s'intéressait déjà la
photographie mais c'était l'époque
c'était les souvenirs c'était palce été
photographié la famille ce n'était pas
encore le film la vidéo comme maintenant
donc c'était la photographie c'était
très important
et puis je suis venu à paris et là les
gens parler pas mal de photographies à
l'époque me suis dit moi ça serait pas
mal non plus que je m'achète un appareil
que j'essaie de voir ce que je peux
faire avec et moi là je me souviens
d'être année avec un ami acheté mon
premier appareil photo après il m'a
demandé des conseils plus tard mais bon
voilà c'est comme ça et puis il ya eu la
fréquentation du faute quand je suis
venu habiter à maurepas
il ya eu une fréquentation du photo club
d'elancourt qui a été très importante
qui était très ouvert sur une
photographie un peu différente à
l'époque de ce qu'on présente est
habituellement dans les photos club les
concours mais une photographie qui était
plus sur le axée sur le le quotidien sur
la rue sur les gens sur aider sur le
réel faire un
un sujet globalement le traité global du
début à la fin et c'est et
et puis aussi il ya eu le crâne le crav
le centre de ressources audiovisuelles
qui était avec la maison pour tous à
l'époque à elancourt sous l'actuelle
médiathèque dans la médiathèque sous
l'actuelle médiathèque 17 mars et çà et
là aussi on a fait une exposition moi je
n'ai pas participé mais je les ai vus
c'était une exposition qui s'appelait
objectifs vitaux vêtements avec objectif
vêtements et avec comme maître de stage
le terek grands photographes de magnum
qui a apporté beaucoup de choses
justement encore donc en fait vous êtes
autodidacte en même temps vous avez leur
partager votre savoir avec d'autres
personnes qui étaient comme vous
passionner et donc vous arrivez à vivre
de ça ou vous aviez un autre métier
comme on fait pas du tout pas du tout
vécu
j'ai eu un autre métier j'étais je
travail à la poste
d'accord j'ai commencé à travailler dans
le 6e arrondissement enfin non dans le
calvados à bayeux j'étais standardiste
mais vous savez les standardistes qui
passent des communications en enfilant
des déneigeurs les troupes
et puis après je suis venu à paris dans
le 6e arrondissement c'est un gros choc
et puis quand je suis venu dans les
yvelines
vous avez pu vous adonner donc à cette
passion en même temps que votre travail
voilà très bien à expliquer le pourquoi
du comment je vais même choisi de
revenir travailler dans les yvelines au
centre de tri montigny le bretonneux
boutonneux pour avoir plus de temps ne
pas perdre de temps dans les transports
ok et alors comment est ce que vous
travaillez qu'elles sont ce que vous
vous donnez des thèmes ou est-ce que
vous allez vous promener avec votre
appareil et vous tombez sur des choses
qui attirent votre regard et vous
photographiez enfin comment vous
organisez je dirais que c'est un peu la
vie qui nous disent tu me guide
mais j'ai des thèmes d'accord sur la
l'exposition dont on pourra parler par
la suite et justement par exemple
regardez cette photo là est ce qu'on
peut en parlait déjà
oui six mois ça a été pris en 1986 à la
colline
la revanche à elancourt elle était alors
en construction elles recevaient tous
les déchets de la ville de saint quentin
en yvelines qui elle même était en
construction
je vous coupe juste ça veut dire quoi
une colline en construction eh bien
non c'était une carrière c'était con à
combler voilà tu sais qui c'est combler
petit à petit normalement avec les
gravats de la construction de la ville
de saint quentin en yvelines système de
vases communicants
voilà pouvait y avoir quelques déchets
sauvages comme ici c'était là matelas
qui a été abandonnée cas une forme un
petit peu bizarre
l'animal voilà aussi aussi et donc
je rencontrais ça la colline et en fin
de compte il ya lille tous les jours je
faisais des photos que je combats un an
vous avez surveiller l'évolution dans un
an je surveillais c'était une
photographie d'humeur plus comme je
pouvais rencontrer ce genre d'objet j'ai
une photo mais ça pouvait aussi plus
sain
plus quelque chose de minéral soit 2 du
fer soit des choses comme ça du béton et
bien par rapport à ce qu'on sent si ce
jour là on est triste on est gay il fait
beau il fait pas beau pas par rapport à
ce lieu mais ça a une influence sur la
façon dont on appréhende le lieu aussi
ce jour là cette photographie là c'était
la wii alors de l'éthique
dès midi
il faut pas totalement noir finalement
tout le monde a ses lunettes et génois
j'aurais pas j'ai pas photographier du
tout
je peux photographiée du tout l'éclipsé
photographier les gens qui étaient venus
voir un lieu où pardon sur la colline la
codi on est toujours sur la colline et
comme c'est le plus haut point des
yvelines et peut-être même de l'île de
france si je suis
eh bien
donc là les gens étaient venus elle est
actuellement fermée sur cette photo là
99 oui 99 oui c'est un peu après que
j'ai fait cette photo mais c'est
toujours la colline de l'armement j'en
ai fait refait quelques unes depuis 86
ben c'est le sait le soir souvent j'y
allais après mais j'avais demandé
l'autorisation à l'entreprise qui gérait
ça donc je pouvais quand même oui c'est
interdit c'est dangereux a dit action
vous voilà c'était assez
c'était assez même ça pouvait être
dangereux et ont demandé j'en ai vu un
soir où les travaux étaient terminés
tout le monde était reparti au début
nous est arrêté et un moment donné j'ai
entendu un grand bruit et un en fait
c'est un fait cement devant moi j'ai
zappé une avalanche non c'était pas très
dangereux
c'est vrai mais il faut faire attention
bon là nous avons eu notre photo qui n'a
rien à voir et qui reflète une autre
partie de votre travail vous avez été
chroniqueur pour le prisme
alors petit des bêtises ou parce que
comme regarder non non non non non non
je vous aurais tu ne sais quoi le prix
alors le prisme c'est un centre de
développement culturel
de la ville dans un lieu de spectacle
aura lieu de création est aussi un lieu
qui est très
et qui fait beaucoup aussi de formation
auprès des élèves qui va dans les écoles
comme danse à l'école qui se fait dans
les écoles
après les élèves restitue leur travail
de l'année on comprend voilà d'accord et
alors qu'est ce que vous y faisiez moi
je photographiais les coulisses
essentiellement c'est à dire les
artistes qui sont dans les coulisses
avant le spectacle je rougis
photographier et mais je n'étais pas
salon mais on a commencé à trois
photographes avaient vaincu collectif
soit france jean-christophe bardot et
philippe pico donc ont photographié
aussi surtout les créations quand il n'y
a qu'un il ya eu beaucoup de traces y
offrir dans les coulisses avant que le
spectacle donné lieu sur scène voilà
prêt cela c'est la répétition d'un
spectacle de danse qui est
qui a déjà été créé mais à chaque fois
que les artistes viennent dans une salle
et en particulier pour la danse ils sont
obligés de répéter ils sont bien là et
là c'est une
photographies de jim de ribeiro c'est
d'avoir un écran qui en fond de scène et
la danseuse
voilà c'est juste vous demandez vous
travaillez en numérique on est gentil
mais je travaille beaucoup en argentique
essentiellement je suis resté à l'argent
qu'ils développent en photo moi même
mais n'apparaît thouars voilà j'ai un
petit laboratoire chez moi je n'ai pour
l'heure les pellicules puis je tiens les
photographies et vous croyez que ça va
continuer l'argentique où sévit
actuellement c'est il ya beaucoup de
jeunes qui s'y intéressent
je ne pense pas non effectivement ça ça
va pas remplacer maintenant le numérique
ça va pas revenir avant numérique mais
j'ai pas les gens cherchent une autre
qualité une autre approche et une
approche du temps parce que la
photographie c'est le temps le numérique
c'est on prend une photo on la regarde
on la consomme et on l'oubli je trouve
et l'argentique on prend une
photographie
on commence par l'oublier elle est sur
la planche contact on va regarder sur la
planche contact on va voir qu'on en a
plusieurs qui vont faire un thème que
l'on est allé dans un sens ou dans un
autre et à ce moment là bien ensemble ça
va faire un thème et on va les ressortir
c'est ça que je trouve intéressant dans
la photographie argentique d'accord la
différence le temps mettant rapport au
temps justement parlant du temps là
actuellement
aujourd'hui jusqu'à jusqu'au 28 mai je
crois oui voilà photos sont exposées
donc à oudon à la tannerie quand on
disait tout à l'heure
voilà donc la fiche paysage autres
territoires vous êtes nombreux à vous
êtes 6 nous sommes 6 2 photographes dont
un seul photographe
c'est l'unique le meilleur 6 1 et nous
avons aussi j'ai avec moi deux amis de
regards parole qin gang jean-françois
oudry utilisés sont neufs et another
chacun nous avons invité un peintre ou
ou mois ci une
c'est un petit feu de la gravure c'est
valérie oiseaux qui a exposé pas très
d'accord
et alors vous allez nous pas aller vite
vite s'il vous plaît de ces photos qui
sont exposés donc là on est dans un
élément plutôt minérale à côté moi mon
travail était essentiellement minérale
segment thème mais moi je m'intéresse au
minéral à la végétation et à l'eau
c'était une photographie à longues sur
mer près d'où je suis né celle ci ça a
été fait
à maints cours sur yvette née dans les
yvelines et dans les yvelines
on se rapproche de la ville si on à
montfort l'amaury ces deux temps apporte
bouder oui auprès de montfort l'amaury
l'étang de la porte bouteilles cassées
l'eau le minéral et le végétal en même
temps il ya tout autre élément de
prédilection sur le paysage mais c'est
le bo où je veux montrer du beau
je veux que les gens s'approprient le
beau je veux qu'ils que l'on revive
redeviennent belle moi je me dis on va
montrer aussi des belles choses
là c'est une photographie j'aime
beaucoup ce genre de photographies parce
qu'il ya le minéral le végétal
on peut penser que c'est le tronc de
l'arbre mais je croyais et l'arbre et
surgit derrière voilà
conclusion il va écouter c'est
formidable ce que vous faites c'est un
très beau travail
les yvelines ont l'air d'être un bel
endroit pour une belle manne bonne manne
de pour un photographe qui l'a pas fait
le regard tel que le vôtre aiguisé et
donc bah on encourage tout le monde à
les voir vos oeuvres à ou devant la
tannerie merci patrice leterrier
merci de m'avoir invité avec plaisir
[Musique]